hello everyone welcome to a really wild
game that was played today in a
simultaneous exhibition unleashes the
simultaneous exhibition was held by
Maxine Rochelle a Grove since the whole
world is in lockdown the the name of the
simultaneous exhibition was the lockdown
Simon and here he faces even Lubitsch
which we've already seen one game you
were play there was some two years ago I
showed it on the channel where he was
well aware he was struggling against the
400 player but he defeated him in the
end and now his opponent is a much
stronger much stronger player one of the
candidates of the 2020 candidates
tournament Maxime vasila graph
so Maxime is why tunnel board as is
usually the case when simultaneous
exhibition is being played and it's
really a quite a game it's full of
surprises
so let's just dive straight straight
into it and Luca asked me a few days ago
what should he play against Maxime I
told him well you should you should face
him where he strongest so as you're
black you know you should prepare the
night off ended the groom the groom
field and whatever he plays you will be
ready so I don't know if he prepared the
groom field as well but he definitely
prepared the night off as you'll see in
this game so Maxime opens with E for
we're c5 the Sicilian defense is on the
board night of three b6 and now B for C
captures Knight captures on the for
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 in the Asics
Luba goes for the knight of variation
against Maxime which is always the way
we want to play chess you want to fight
someone where where they are strongest
so Bishop to e3 a continuing the
development we have E 5 kicking away the
night this is the the most popular move
in this variation Knight back the b3 and
now Bishop to e7 just preparing the
castle Maxime goes f3 he strengthens his
efore pawn I saw the knife can at some
point be shifted over to d5 if needed we
have Bishop to e6 and now Queen to d2
developing the Queen and preparing the
Castle queenside so it's gonna be is it
gonna be a wild game already you can see
as the castles will be on opposite sides
of the board we have castles by black
and a queenside castle by Maxine and
there are a couple of ways you could
play this position a five is a popular
option I bt7 it's a popular option but
Lou ball goes for B five immediately he
knows this will be a race so he wants
the attack on the queenside as soon as
possible and Maxime doesn't want to be
behind on the attack so he starts
expanding on the kingside we have G four
and now before we had Knight to a4 and
here a very well sort of a critical
position already a lot of a lot of games
reach this position for example there is
a no move a five as the Queen is kind of
threatening to pick up the beef or pawn
so a five can be played there is a known
game Peter Svidler played against the
court Hanson in 1995 where a five was
played and thus wheeler was was able to
win that game so it's not considered the
greatest of options and there is one
game where d5 was played right away a
public Rd played against Garry Kasparov
in 1997 and Kasparov won that game very
nicely but here Knight B to d7 is played
and this is in fact the best at the best
try for black as there is no actual
danger of this pawn being grabbed if you
capture the pawn then you allow black
this d5 free move which you always want
to play in the Sicilian and after you
deal with this attack on the Queen then
even d4 becomes an option just to
grabbing more space in the center which
would be excellent for black so instead
after this Knight B to d7 with g5
continuing the expansion on the Kings
side pushing back the night we have
night to h5 and now now comes Luke to g1
and this is one of those positions where
where that even is such a such a great
theoretician like Maxime for sherrilyn
Grove didn't have on the at home on the
board because here it's actually best to
capture on b4 point is that now b5 is a
bit different because because of a
certain something because here you go
Queen to a5 and now now for example if
you go d4 right away then it's it's it's
okay for white you will just trade
Queen's Queen captures on the a to
Brooke a capture sandy eight and better
back to d2 and your g5 point is nicely
protected however as
this Queen to a5 move black also has now
the option of going Bishop captures on
g5 and after Bishop characters on g5 you
will go Bishop captures and now after
Queen captures ng Phi with check King to
be won and now this is the point that d4
is now impossible because of the simple
Knight captures on d4 you do not allow
black this expansion in the center
because now if captures the Queen on g5
is hanging but those are the intricacies
of this well neither of craziness in
this position but okay rook the g1 by
maksim and now a5 now you strengthen the
pawn and now there is one game in the
database where King Tubby one was played
but Maxime goes for h4 here and it is as
of move 15 that we have a completely new
game so Maxime continues his expansion
on the Kings side and a Luba has to
figure out how to continue his attack on
the Queen side so Queen to c7 ah it's a
very natural developing square for the
Queen you want to connect your rooks
bring your rook into the game and start
an attack somehow and here night the a1
as Maxime is expecting the the attack to
happen on the C file he already puts his
knight here as one of the defenders of
the C 2 square and it is a weird square
for the knight but if you've ever seen
Maxime playing the knight or for the
groom fold or anything like that you
know that Maxime is no stranger when it
comes to putting Knights to strange
places
so rook F the c8 just bringing the rook
into the attack and now b3 probably
probably to at some point allow ideas
like a Bishop to c4 and also you will be
able to bring this Knight back maybe to
b2 and b3 and then into the game this
way but for the moment this night is
pretty much needed here preventing black
further expansion with a 4 so nice to f4
this is now possible as even though it
looks like you can win a pawn it it's
not actually a free point if characters
captures and captures then Knight the c5
will be will be very strong and it's
just it's just a very difficult position
to play with white for example if
characters captures black is just
dominating here a4 is coming you're
gonna bust open the position and if
everything goes well you should win the
game so here
Kings the b1 by Maxine and
rook 88 probably with the idea that once
the knight moves you don't want to allow
white any access to the e to the b6
square we have looked a c1 now further
adding more defenders to the to the c2
upon and now the freeing move d5 may be
a bit premature but you know if it works
why not nice to see five on the other
hand probably probably goes as well
because white should never capture with
the knight and allow black to bust open
the position with a four but okay we
have d5 now busting open the position
and here comes Bishop captures on f4
we have four characters and now pawn
captures on d5 so b5 comes with with a
pawn sacrifice for Bishop to f5 now
adding another attacker to the game
Bishop to d3 maxime just blocks it with
Bishop captures on d3 and now
unfortunately you cannot capture with
the Queen because of night c5
again you will overload the night here
and after captures captures again black
will get a four in and then it's just a
tough position for white to play so
instead C captures hoping to the trade
off some of the some of the rooks and
now Queen to e5 Queen to d6 a bit more
precise but Maxie makes sure that the
Queen goes back to the d6 square we rook
to e1 with an attack on the Queen so you
have to move it Queen to d6 and now a
nice root lift by maksim rook the c6
point is that you cannot you cannot move
the Queen with Queen captures here
because before capturing the bishop you
will first capture on c8 with check and
then you're just gonna pick up a free
bishop so that's not that's not possible
so we have rook captures and c6 pawn
captures and again the idea is the same
if you capture the pond and rook
captures Bishop here so Luba goes for
the for the for the for the best move
Knight to b6 again you want to dislodge
this night somehow from here continue
pushing on the Queen side but you also
don't mind it the trade so Knight
captures we have rook captures now
threatening to pick up the c6 pawn with
rook and here best for white is just
just to play rook to c1 and after this
trade here cat
scatters and captures white gets to pick
up the f4 pawn and the game continues
however Maxine found a brilliant tactic
here or or so he thought
well he tricked me definitely he played
Queen to c2 and I was so I was following
the game live and I was like ah okay
Queen to c2 I get it but I didn't get it
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out why you cannot capture
on c6 with the rook while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting that you can in fact capture
on c6 with the rook and that is in fact
the best move and the tactic that that
Maxim thought that works for him
actually works against him this is what
I thought when I when I saw Queen to c2
I said okay this is impossible because
of simply rook captures on e7 and after
you capture here you have one check only
movie screen to Ephrata now you trade
and now Knight captures and c2 white is
up a piece game over
problem is I missed one move the move I
missed after this after this Queen to
eat you after this rook captures and c6
is that if you go for rook captures and
e7 black has a different idea black
doesn't have to capture the Queen and
this is the the essence of the game of
the position basically so feel free to
pause the video now and try to find the
DOE winning move for black here well I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's it's a beautiful
tuition - and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's King the f8 really a powerful move
now you're saying your queen is still
under attack and your rook is also under
attack even though you're temporarily up
a piece but it doesn't really matter
there's no way for you to keep an eye on
both threats so what you could do is
move the rook and allow route
character's queen but that's a winning
endgame for black and another thing if
you just move the Queen then just Queen
captures here yup the exchange and
White's position is just terrible due to
the open White King and black would win
this game easily so this is what MVL
found out when Lugo captured with rook
captures and c6 the rook captures any
seven was impossible and now he had to
retreat he played Queen to e2 now just
put pressure on the bishop here and
worked the c7 defending Bishop to f8 was
also an option just getting it out of
the way so it doesn't have to be a
target any longer but okay rook to c7
definitely holds Knights the c2 finally
MVL starts to bring in the night into
the game and now g6 making some room for
the king so you don't have to worry
about back ranked weaknesses and in the
future you might even have plans of
fiend carrying the bishop to create some
threats against the white king with the
Queen and the bishop so Queen e5 and we
all here of course puts his queen and
this diagonal doesn't allow you would
start an attack and offers a Queen trade
and queen c6 you don't want to allow a
Queen trade when you're well when you're
your opponent's king is exposed and you
have attacking chance it's also Queen
captures and c2 is just a nice threat
and here rogue back to c1 you the
problem is if you go back with the Queen
then again you allow ideas like Queen c3
and you might run into some problems
here so you definitely want to keep your
Queen on this diagonal here so look the
c1 defending Queen captures against
Queen captures in c2 and the knock comes
Bishop to d6 pushing the Queen back
while keeping an eye on the pawn here
and now Queen to e4 offering a queen
trade which would also connect White's
pawns and here black has to decide what
are the trade Queens or to try and keep
the tension with Queen to c3
here you go captured he decided to trade
Queens Queen Queen to c3 that does seem
like it offers much more for black for
example if you can get Bishop to e5 when
you you might even get some checkmating
ideas problem is a white always has
Queen before and you can always pretty
much force a Queen trade now the Queen
and the bishop are under attack
and once you defend the bishop you're
gonna we're gonna see a nice trade here
and again you can go Knight the e1 or
something rogue d1 to defend the pawn
and the game continues but the black
should always be better in this same
game however Queen characters on e4 was
played we have F captures on e4 d
captures on e4 is also possible but then
white has no past bonds and this way
white has at least a fat past deep on
but it also gives black the past f born
I accidentally pushed that and here we
have looked the c3 immediately going
after this pawn here and the problem
with pushing the pawn to d4 is then you
white black and push f3 and it's already
defended by by the rook and then you can
get your bishop in push push it all the
way to f2 white could be in some
problems so instead we have nice the e1
now offering a rook trade also guarding
the d3 pawn but here for the final time
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only good move for black here
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and finding such a nice
push as it always comes to with passed
pawns
they must be pushed so f3 here for
everyone else who wants to enjoy the
show and now the problem is if you go
for the rook first f2 wins the game
there is no way to stop promotion so you
have to do something about it
Knight captures on f3 was played and now
rook captures on d3
and now that the white zone we passed
pawn is eliminated now you can read a
little easier and also plays on both
sides of the board the black has a
bishop so blacks black is a little
better here with E 5 chasing away the
bishop Bishop to e7 and now rook to f1
here trying to pile up on the f7 pawn
somehow if white can get an ID h 2 to g4
maybe to h6 and then the the pawn on f7
that's on a light square could become an
issue since you're really you really do
have control of the f6 square but rook
to e3
it was move pretty much solves every
problem now even if you try something
like this if you want to give it up for
for this idea black can even just play
h5 and completely nullify White's
threats now if you want to defend it you
have to go back Knight f3 basically
we've just wasted a move so after rook
III King c2 by white MVL now starts
bringing the King into the game King g7
with King to d2 and now Bishop to c5
defending the rook and while the rook
controls
all of these squares there's no way for
the White King to enter the game any
further we have King to d1 and here you
could try somehow to push with black but
for the moment King to g8 with King to
d2 and now King g7 if black wanted
wanted more black would probably have to
go all the way down here but then it's
it's a question how would you cross this
with with the night night guarding this
Square pong guarding this Square and
it's it's very unlikely that you even
can but Luba says here to anvil you're a
grandmaster you're the one who has to
push if you want so we have King to be
one and Luba repeats King to g8 we have
King to d2 and King to g7 and it was in
this position that MVL offered the draw
and you go I imagine happily accepted
the draw so really really incredible
incredible game especially like I said
when you take into account that two
years ago when you check out that game I
will put a link to that game into the
description below if you want to check
it out and and then this game the
quality of the game just just shows you
that if you stick to it if you you know
learn just a little little at least a
little every day and the progress will
be made and then of course you have to
prepare for a game against mvl if you
want to play a game of this caliber
which is just which is just incredible
it's really a remarkable game with a lot
of incredible tactical shots especially
that that moment where I thought that
black black is just gone but in the end
it was it wasn't working here after this
Queen to c2 idea I thought that that for
sure this is losing but then King to f8
wow what a move
I mean who would have found that but
yeah Luba obviously had it figured out
and mvl saw that it didn't work and then
he had go in the retreat and it just
didn't work so dr. King to g7 they drew
the game and well this is it's not a
small thing you know getting a draw from
one of the candidates of the can 2020
candidates tournament they are so
congratulations to even on this and this
great achievement and yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like
think after Canaria for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on Leela and stockfish
continue to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day